‘No bug left behind’ is the motto of this ant species,
found in southern regions of Africa.
When the ants hunt termites—a risky prey—
the colony sticks together,
marching into battle in columns,
and making sure even injured ants make it back.
Large ants called “majors”
break up soil around termite nests during a raid,
while smaller “minor” ants slip through the cracks
to extract their meal.
Soldier termites fight back,
and ants lose limbs and antennae in the scuffle.
After the fight, the ants line up to go home,
carrying termite carcasses along for a post-battle feast.
When predators, like spiders,
see injured ants struggling home,
they know they’re in for an easy snack.
So majors stick around after the fight,
tracking the scent of a pheromone that signals injury.
When an injured ant is found,
the major grabs the fallen soldier in its mandibles
and carries it home to recover safely in the nest.
To see what became of those injured ants,
researches created laboratory nests
and hunting grounds
and marked the injured with paint.
Ninety-five percent of those hurt ants
marched alongside their brethren on future raids.
The number of ants rescued each day
is about the same as daily ant births,
meaning rescues help the colony stay strong
and prepared to fight another day.